the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
[Music]
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones
foreshadowing video
before i get started i just want to give
everyone a heads up about the new
giveaway
i recently gave away a copy of the world
of ice and fire book
but now i want to start a new one
because there is something else i want
to do this time
if you are interested in entering the
giveaway just make sure you stay until
the end of the video to find out all the
details
alright now in today's video i want to
talk about something i noticed when i
was just randomly watching one of the
very first promos for game of thrones
as i'm sure most of you know hbo always
releases trailers and other video promos
before a new season or one of their
shows comes out
they typically do this to promote the
show and generate some excitement from
the fans
i know we're all patiently waiting for
the season 8 trailer to come out but i
want to talk about one of the very first
promos hbo ever made for game of thrones
because i think there is a very big clue
in this preview that is actually setting
up something we could see in the final
season
seven years ago hbo released a short
video about four months before the pilot
episode even aired
now what's interesting is i think they
did reveal a big clue that was basically
hiding in plain sight
as far as i know i haven't seen anyone
else make a video about this before so
let's jump right into it
i want to show you the video because
when i watched it the other night i did
notice something kind of strange
but it also kind of makes sense because
of the direction the show is heading in
now i do realize some of you may say i
am reaching a little too far with this
one which is understandable
but hopefully you can see where i'm
coming from after i explain
why i think it is a big clue as we all
know over the past two seasons
game of thrones has started to reveal
more and more information about jon snow
for years the truth about jon snow's
parents was one of the best kept secrets
in westeros
when the television show first begins we
are told
jon snow is ned stark's bastard he had
always claimed that jon snow is his son
but his mother was always a mystery
because ned would never talk about who
she was
and we later find out why in season six
they finally revealed that jon snow was
not ned stark's son
he was actually the son of rhaegar
targaryen and ned stark's sister lyanna
stark
ned had to keep this a secret because
all the other targaryens were being
killed
and ned could not allow that to happen
to his sister's child
no matter who the father was obviously
this was a massive revelation
because we were led to believe almost
all of the targaryens were dead
but the bloodline lives on through
daenerys targaryen and now
jon snow this would make jon snow half
targaryen and half stark
which makes him a very special character
in a story that has the overall title
a song of ice and fire which is exactly
what jon snow is
then in season 7 we find out rhaegar and
lyanna
actually got married before they had
their child so after all this time not
only is jon snow not a bastard
but he's actually the true heir to the
iron throne now
what's crazy is i think they were
hinting at this before the show even
aired
which is why i want to show their first
preview before they even released their
first trailer
if you've read the books you can also
see that george rr martin was setting
this
up in some of the very first chapters as
well now in the preview they show a
handful of characters sitting on the
iron throne
and one of those characters is of course
jon snow now i do want to say
i don't think this was just a clue
simply because jon snow is in the
preview
what really intrigued me is the
characters they decided to leave out of
the preview
and i'll tell you why unfortunately i'm
not going to be able to show you the
full video in one clip
because when i tried to upload the whole
preview i immediately got a copyright
claim put on the video
so what i had to do was break the video
clip down into two sections
thankfully it's only one minute long in
total therefore i had to split it up
into two 28 second clips
that way i don't get a claim or strike
on the video so
let me play the first half of the
preview then i will play the second half
of the preview
make sure you pay very close attention
to the characters they show sitting on
the iron throne
winter's coming this one will be long
and the dark things will come with it i
saw what i saw
i know they did it in my bones i know it
won't talk and if he does i'll kill him
i don't want to be his queen
i want to go home my brother has a sword
but i have my mind
you might not have my name
so as you can see in the first half of
the preview they only show a couple
characters sitting on the iron throne
now keep this in mind this was to
promote the first season of the show
this promo came out in january of 2011
and the show aired its first episode in
april of 2011. the first character they
show sitting on the iron throne is ned
stark
that makes sense because ned stark is
basically the main character
or the main protagonist in the first
season his family is the very first
family we are introduced to because how
stark is obviously one of the major
houses in the story
and this is a generational saga we will
eventually see a lot of the story
unfold through the eyes of the stark
children also if you look at the main
logo for game of thrones
you can see the four major houses from
the story how stark house lannister
house targaryen and house baratheon the
second person they show sitting on the
iron throne is ned stark's wife
that also makes sense because ned and
his wife are two very important
characters at the beginning of the story
this shows us who the leaders are from
house stark one of the four major houses
in the series
after they show lady catelyn the preview
starts to pick up some speed
it flashes back and forth between tyrion
jaime and cersei
as we all know they are the main players
for house lannister
also one of the four major houses not to
mention
cersei is the queen at the beginning of
the story because she is married to
robert baratheon
there is no denying how important these
lannister characters are
all three of them are still alive
inactive in the story to this day
now this is when the preview takes a
shift because they only show
two children sitting on the iron throne
in the entire preview
after it shows the lannisters then it
shows daenerys and jon
who are both teenagers at the start of
the story these are the two youngest
characters in the preview
and we now know they are arguably two of
the most important characters
at least in terms of saving the realm
but we don't figure this out until much
later
so if you're watching this promo before
season 1 comes out
you have to start wondering why did they
choose to show these two characters
overall the other younger characters in
the show well i think daenerys makes
sense because she is pretty much
the only targaryen that we know of
besides her brother but they did show
daenerys holding a dragon egg while she
was sitting on the throne
so it's obvious why she may be a little
more important than her brother
also you need to show one of the
targaryens in the preview because they
are one of the four major houses in the
story
now keep in mind these are just my
opinions on why they decided to show
these specific characters for the first
promo
then we get the jon snow if you're
watching this video before the first
season comes out or even
if you watch this video after you finish
watching the first season you gotta be
asking yourself
why the hell did they show jon snow
unless it was foreshadowing something
big
think about jon's status in season one
he is literally last in line in hal
stark
he's a bastard who just joined the
night's watch since he was a bastard
we knew he had no rights to anything but
then he joins the night's watch
which knocks him down even further so
why would you show jon snow in the promo
sitting on the iron throne
when you could have shown any of the
other legitimate stark children
you're already showing ned and catelyn
so why not show one of their legitimate
children
who have a much better chance at playing
the game for the iron throne
i mean rob stark literally becomes king
in the north
even joffrey baratheon becomes king of
the seven kingdoms
but you don't show either one of them
you show jon snow instead
a bastard in the night's watch that
doesn't make any damn sense
however it does make sense now because
we now know who he truly is
before i go any further let me show you
the second half of the preview because
they do show two more
peace characters fear distrusting me was
the wisest thing you've done
everyone who isn't us is an enemy
you kill me your brother's a dead man
[Music]
so as you can see in the second half of
the clip they show robert baratheon and
littlefinger
i think them showing robert baratheon
makes sense because he is the king of
the seven kingdoms at the start of the
show
and he's ned stark's best friend now i
will say littlefinger was kind of an
interesting choice to show
because he's not a member of any other
four major houses but he is arguably one
of the most dangerous characters in the
show
he basically set everything in motion by
having john aaron killed
and we also come to find out he is
trying to take the iron throne for
himself
he reveals this to sansa moments before
jon snow becomes king in the north
however i think the big key here is the
fact that daenerys and jon are the only
two characters they show
from the younger generation that will
eventually take over
dany's brother had a better claim than
she did at the beginning of the show
but they left him out because they knew
he would be dead before the first season
even ended
but most importantly they showed the
bastard from the north
the fact that they showed ned and
catelyn stark but none of their
legitimate children
has to tell you something at the start
of this show
what were the chances jon snow could end
up on the iron throne
even littlefinger had better odds than
jon and he wasn't even a part of any of
the major houses
if las vegas would have put out odds of
who would sit on the iron throne at the
time they released this promo
jon snow would have been near the bottom
of that list not only was he a bastard
but he was in the damn night's watch
the one place that gives up their rights
to do anything but serve at the wall for
an eternity
and john had no claim to begin with now
in order for me to make my main point
let's take a look at the imagery from
the preview
look at how each character is sitting on
the iron throne
this is how ned stark has shown it first
you can barely even see him
it's basically just his silhouette then
we see catelyn stark
and this is how she was shown at first
now we can actually see her
but she's still not directly centered in
the frame the iron throne is even moving
as they show her look at how they show
tyrion lannister
he's not directly centered in the frame
either and it's showing him from his
side
they do the same thing with jaime
lannister they do the same thing with
cersei lannister
who is the actual queen at the time i
might add
and they even do the same thing with
daenerys targaryen they even do this
with robert baratheon who is the actual
king of the seven kingdoms at the time
they show them all from the side without
being directly centered in the frame
and the iron throne is even spinning
almost as if they're trying to knock
them off of it
now look at how they show jon snow he is
perfectly centered in the frame
and the iron throne is not moving at all
then it shows another quick image of jon
sitting on the iron throne with ghost at
his side
look at how epic it looks when they show
jon snow
that looks like a [ __ ] king now let
me put the cherry right on top of this
look at the thumbnail hbo has used for
this promo
ever since they uploaded it seven years
ago is it a coincidence they made jon
snow the face of this video
the iron throne preview i don't think so
this was set in motion before the show
even aired its first episode
then of course in season two we get even
more symbolism about who is the actual
heir to the iron throne when daenerys
targaryen literally sees snow
falling on the throne she never touches
it but boy oh boy is it covered in snow
now let me give you the details about
the new giveaway then i'll quit wasting
your time
for this giveaway i wanted to do
something a little different than what i
usually do
this time i want to give away a game of
thrones t-shirt so what i will do is
whoever wins can go onto the hbo website
and pick out whatever shirt
and size they want so if you would like
to enter
click on the link that is provided down
below as always
you can enter up to five times to
increase your chances of winning
good luck everyone and thank you all for
taking the time to watch the video
i really appreciate that also i want to
thank all my patreon supporters
i love you all and i hope you have a
great day i'll see you soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you